giorgio ho amici miei oggi siamo sul
secondo volevo togliere gli occhiali in
modo figo ma sembra mia nonna
spero che vi sia piaciuto più episodi ma
fatelo ci siamo il secondo è una serie
gli occhiali mi lasciano un segno non
sono fatto per le cose intelligenti
questo si sapeva
secondo e bisogna dimenticare buona
visione va bè ragazzi allora andiamo
nella botola di sotto che in teoria
dovrebbe non ricordo dove la botta una
caffetteria caffetteria normalmente
chiamata sala da pranzo c'è il cane
ancora c'è ancora il cane non lo
paghiamo let's go
inside bike perfetto store hausen trans
di qua dovrebbe essere mio papà ho il
mio papà e dove spreca ma sono cieco io
c'è qualcuno davanti a me c'era qualcuno
giuro l'ho visto mai palla di neve entra
per favore palla di neve a io comando
farà di neve ma sto male
sblocca la porta palatina e sicuramente
sarà chiusa ma c'è un oggetto olio per
lanterna quindi niente si è cagato
addosso politi nel mica scemo sarà ue è
chiusa proprio foglio per la siba come
entro io mi sarei entrare qua dentro
ok pd che parla di aveva fatto bene a
scappare e di neve non ci credo sto male
mi tirò gli ometti l'olio d'oliva olio
metti l'olio perché non funziona per
favore
metti l'olio madonna mia che ansia di
vivere toglimi la cig mentre non leggo
c'è qualcuno dietro di me perfetto parla
di neve domandato patinata amica inca in
camera sua casa a tornare in camera sua
ma non ci credo l'abbia possibile all
apostolo a niente è tornato di essere
messo di non dormire va dormi per
telefoni comunque ragazzi analizzando
gli oggetti che ho adesso l'olio quello
per lanterna è lo l'accendino carico
perché parla di neve mi ha portato al
caso della cina quindi devo trovare un
qualcosa qui dal fuoco in generale non
so cosa però qualcosa
o mio dio è uscito quella roba lì è
andato nel cesso come salve la nostra
lista lista di sali tranquillo
tranquillo sali style.it ti caga cioè ti
hanno già pagato a quanto parlava una
turistico al suo stylist e li ascolta
serve un accedino devo scendere qualcosa
carta igienica ma è stato un incontro
piacevole posso dargli fuoco a sti cosi
[Musica]
a devo bruciarli ma come l'accendino
bruciali ma chi se ne frega vai dagli
poco brucia tutto brava zia brucia tutto
vai così minchia camera né a padre
figlio brucia brucia brucia fa male eh
bè fa male brucia brava zia così si fa
capito tutto un over si torna indietro
italiani sono un essere bruciati e io
passo molto bene e questo è dove lavora
papà perfetto quindi fammi salvare face
qualcosa taxi d'armi room non so che
cosa sia ma sono un sacco di boccetta
ci sono bambini dod bambini doppioni nel
nelle teche bambini ok brutta faccenda
poiché avuto un bambino come sei caduto
è caduto l'occhio va bene un occhio è
sempre quello mi manca cioè la buona
collezione molto ricco di di cose
mancano le mani anche però un occhio
cielo vabbè lasciamo perdere
andiamo avanti che è meglio papa maria
maria maria mistress signorina massei
ferita a tranquilla tutto bene dove papà
ho sentito urlare dalla mia stanza maria
che questo è successo a sua moglie e sua
moglie e mamma è morta lei mia mamma
ma che cosa intendi maria maria continua
a dire maria non è colpa mia e dovrebbe
essere morta
però c'è un uomo pelato che risolve i
nostri problemi quando non li capiamo
cosa hai visto maria mamma è morta vero
che cosa sta succedendo non dirmi che la
maledizione risolverà i suoi sospetti
soltanto se cerchi disposte che strana
persona che losco figuro vabbè maria
style e maria io salvo la partita o
maria salvador per chi ero mi amor dove
vado dentro verso ciao papà ci sono un
sacco di bimbi nuti nelle teche papa
bambinelli non ci credo mia madre la
riconosco dagli dagli occhi mamma com'è
possibile che sia mia madre sei tu
aspetta mi vengono bene gli urli
melodrammatici quella era veramente
mamma quindi è tornati indietro con la
maledizione giusto non l'hai notato ma
questo pelato spuntano ovunque come c'è
sempre un uomo pelato nelle vostre
stanze che vi osserva e voi non lo
sapete
quindi lei realizzato si è tua mamma
quindi andrei aver scoprire la verità
poi tipo di più secondo me non è vero
ragazzi secondo me l'ha uccisa mio padre
non lo so però o mio dio minore
e vabbè teste ciao c'è una testa alla
tocco where is money che vivere dove
dov'è il mio corpo ma ce ne sono un bosh
e di quello che dice io che è successo
guarda qua non ti aiuto st 18 guardi
sotto i vari e quaquaraquà guarda qui ma
non seguire me seguì la testa la testa
dentro la permesso
c'è un operato che non è colori prima
però ci torno dopo permesso che anzi
rivivere
ma è la stanza all'altra quella dove
entrata palla di neve prima questo un
pezzo della scala o che adesso posso
andare nel lattico
cos'è questa roba ma è un corpo su un
corpo morto passo ma che schifo via
verso lattico se palla di neve sta bene
gli ho problemi importante questo gioco
non muoia paganini attico qualcosa
luccica nel barile
prendi le le cose che luccicano i barili
no cos'è questo oggetto che mi farà a
proseguire nel gioco spiegare questo è
una mini motosega at no non so veramente
cio una motosega
ma chi figata ha poi perché faccia da
solo nella cantina va bene quanto
nostalgico
mi ricordo che mio padre mi faceva
giocare ma cosa ti faccio giocarono
motosega poiché padre aia che cosi
facendo perché a vedi che non glielo sta
dicendo la scusa papa voleva uccidere
gli altri bambini non è un giocattolo è
molto pericoloso hai capito non giocare
corrompe come queste ancora vai vai
distruggi tutto distrugge mai trovato la
gemma ora questo non serve a niente però
se vi ricordate c'è a vichy anche lei e
non possono equipaggiare la motosega
ma possiamo mangiare solo in determinati
ambienti e dove comincerà il coso il
barile che è successo sembra che
qualcosa mi abbia afferrato la gamba ma
che no no
ma chi la voleva motosega tagli agli il
braccio ma come ieri a scappa via
chi è che il mi ha afferrato e chi era
scappa scappa veloce
cosa è successo mio dio o s'è mosso 1
corribile moving no longer non si muove
più
va beh uno si è mosso vabbè ora che la
moto sia comunque devo vuoi stare dalle
tue parti mannaia te stai lontano come
non mi toccare la testa la testa
vieni qua prende la testa ed hunter
è cristo l'ho trovata bene sono contento
di esser di stato d'aiuto
io ti ho aiutato no dammi una mano tu
grazie ai minimi su miss mister e io sei
veramente brutto prendi dei capelli a se
n'è andato proprio contratto una gemma
vabbè ciao zio allora ascolta ora un po
piace trovata prima miracle blade è una
gemma e basta cosa serve allora stato
sega la barricata la barricata di legno
ok prova andarci vai ha scoperto una
nuova ala della casa molto molto più
allegra di quella di prima pensate let's
go my friends salve possibile parlare
con lei è chiusa dall'interno
faccio una leva lì non posso vedere non
posso vedere niente zia non c'è gli
occhi ne ho trovato uno prima di là ne
vuoi uno quell'uomo mi ha rubato gli
occhi ma che brutta roba fa mio padre ce
n'è uno aspetta da incaglio darglielo o
degli occhi quei beni che ciò che gli
occhi li ho trovati prima alle
bancarelle ce ne sono mica tuoi gente
cose accadono il suo posto salve mi dica
benvenuti a casa lei di mi dite come do
gli occhi alla banda la tipa tutti stai
sempre fermo qua no molto bene al
secchio il secchio dell'acqua non ho ben
capito cosa serva in realtà l'acqua però
so che c'è un secchio la uso ho preso
dell'acqua che me ne fa ap spegnere il
cammino con l'acqua non ho idee non mi
chiedete quale sia il motivo però lo
spegniamo spendi spendi puoi andare si
entra entra nel camino a caso entra nel
camino o mio dio c'è un buco nel camino
simpatico però aspetta prima di entrare
magari salviamo c'è una ragazza che anzi
ma da qui a è la tipa dagli occhi dagli
occhi
vai vai dalle gli occhi subito
perfetto sono riuscito a fare tutto
quello che volevo fare incredibile non
succede quasi mai nei giochi ma
prendiamo di arrivare ai moli salve che
ho dato io gli occhi è uno stato
bravissimo
ho trovato i miei occhi si ma metti te
li metti di tipo la cover del telefono
me eccolo lì il suo rumore mi è piaciuto
un sacco
ciao sono stato io ho trovati gli occhi
kagami per cortesia
posso vedere posso vedere grazie grazie
prego figure che cos'è una gemma va bene
c'è una ghigliottina simpatica sostanza
c'è una leva tira
ho aperto il portone gigante let's go
non so neanche come ho fatto
poiché siamo arrivati finalmente al
punto per proseguire non o oggetti
neanche uno ceo questi qua che però non
ho capito però servono sono
collezionabili più che altro che gli
oggetti non ne ho neanche uno però
possiamo proseguire le cure mediche
scale gigantesche restò andando
all'inferno sono andata sotto le scale
sono tornata qui e non andiamo da
nessuna parte così ciao mi sai dire
perché sto continuando a fare questa
cosa si aiuta mix mai a farmi andare
avanti basta
che palle nel continuare questa mi
seguirà per tutto il resto la mia vita
allora mi fai andare avanti per cortesia
c'è un mostro ma dove li avevamo il giro
lungo e c'è un mostro dove andate alla
zia sparita è sparita la zia
[Musica]
e successo i palati pass è andata per i
cavoli suoi
questo è io mi sono ri incarnato nella
tipa cosa papa a ok questo quando la
tipa è morta a gli sta facendo rivivere
di corriere la tipa come se lei lista
essersi impersonando cosa sta facendo
papa
lasciami con le mani meravigliose papa
fermati sono io orribile scappa scappa
non si capisce proprio per questo gioco
si chiama my father vero mamma mia che
ansia ma mi posso tornare indietro
adesso mi fai passare dove la prima non
c'è non c'è più ma come non si muove ma
no io non portarla fuori
vabbè c'è albus silente simpatica
aspettativa album ma poi c'è un altro
passaggio tra l'altro cos'è un cesso
d'oro c'è un oggetto è nota c'è una
chiave nel cesso poi prendere mi fa un
po schifo però prendi da questa è
maestro muten di dragon voi cos'è un
vecchio uomo che punta che stai a bontà
sei scemo
intanto spostata di qualche usa dove
andiamo nella direzione dell'uomo ok non
si romperà facilmente ma usa la motosega
neanche con la motosega cavalca questo
cesso
no palle di neve ci sono i conigli che
somiglia la palla di neve ma no chiuso i
conigli nelle boccettine che brutta
persona ma finché ammazzati le persone
ancora ancora ci stavi dentro uno che
ammazzi coni di sé proprio perfido non
voglio guardare invece con gli umani è
tutto a posto
vabbè andiamo avanti c'è un cos'è sta
roba perché mi hai fatto questo non ti
perdonerò mai mai
quindi ragazzuoli concluso il secondo
episodio di matt fater spero vi stia
piacendo la serie è veramente figo ceppi
giuro è una delle storie più belle più
raccapriccianti anche però più belle che
abbia mai giocato sul canale 32 ragazzi
se vi è piaciuto il momento è un mi
piace anche dai social comunicato dalla
descrizione
se non sarà così rischiate era ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo visto dai
ragazzi
[Musica]